all right well yesterday we talked to
some folks from UConn and they were
unhappy with the fact that Linda Sarsour
she started the women's marches she said
some anti-semitic comments in the past
and she has been invited to the school
to speak and she is gonna be on campus
anyone can come and watch her I don't
know if they're selling tickets or how
they're handling that but no counselors
needed but yet when you go to UConn
because I guess they're offended by you
and maybe you're dangerous they have to
have police there they have to have
counselors there what was your reaction
when you heard that they were inviting
Linda Sarsour I mean certainly shows
that the snowflake syndrome seems to
centralise on one side that really it's
only the left that is filled with with
horrible snowflakes who are interested
in shutting down to bethe college
campuses and mandating that there be
hundreds of police officers and a ban on
public on the general public from
attending my lectures when when its
limits our sewer who is infinitely worse
in terms of controversy than I am mean
this is a woman who recently defended
people who were defending louis
farrakhan and she is treated as just a
normal part of the political debate at
UConn as I'm glad that you can't had me
but the fact they had to take all these
precautions in order for me to come and
then they had to warn the students as
though I was going to scar them for life
but Linda Sarsour who says really awful
things on a regular basis comes and
there's no warning to the population
just shows how leftist the
administration is I make an observation
it doesn't seem to bother you not as
long as I get to talk to to the students
I'm a happy camper and and again I'm
always grateful to administration's for
allowing me there but I can't be
bothered by all the stupid people who
want to shut down debate I mean if we
did that then we wouldn't have a country
absolutely there's the whole thing about
what the the hecklers veto we're if they
complain about somebody you want end up
getting sent far away from the main
place but apparently UConn said they
went through the same protocol with her
that they did with you ultimately though
that's what you want to hear on campus
she's got some she's got some
extraordinary views you've got some
views you want to hear all the views you
don't want any editing no question I
mean I just wish that we'd have the same
treatment it's our sewer and again some
of it's on the administration and some
of it is on the the ante for folks and
in some of the people who are radical
again the radicals don't exist on the
right there's not a lot of people who
are attempting to shut down sour sewer
work or threatening the event with
violence there's a reason that the
administration didn't feel that police
officers were necessary in the same
numbers as in my events and that's not
because of the controversy ality of my
views that's because they're a bunch of
radicals on the left who legitimately
are committed and fascist fashion to
shutting down free speech in a way that
people on the right generally are not
that your show and those ideas can be
found on your podcast right yep
absolutely check that out I appreciate
it pay for bug guys thank you van